je pense que c'était une très mauvaise
idée d'abord c'est curieux de problème
de méthode la majorité se réfère souvent
au programme du président 20 du candidat
macron qui s'applique pour le coup ce
sujet n'était absolument pas dans le
programme du candidat macro il est né
comme ça dans la tête d'un député même
pas discuter avec son co rapporteurs bon
la méthode est pas trés pas très correct
et puis en plus c'est un grand
cafouillage dans la majorité vous avez
entendu la ministre qui dément les
propos du rapporteur un autre député
président d'une commission qui dément
également les propos du rapporteur d'un
grand cafouillage dans dans la majorité
mais pour revenir sur le fond c'est une
mauvaise idée parce que il ya deux
choses dans la politique familiale il ya
le quotient familial qui permet d'avoir
un abattement de 2 sur les impôts et
quelles que soient ses revenus mais j'ai
envie de dire en fonction en considérer
que l'arrivée d'un enfant dans une
famille quelles que soient ses revenus
ne peut pas ne doit pas quitter le
pouvoir d'achat c'est pour encourager
une politique nataliste et notre pays
tiers aussi de sa démographie plus
positif que d'autres pays européens une
force
donc je pense que l'universalité du
quotient familial est une bonne chose il
faut différencier politique familiale et
politique sociale bien sûr parce que il
faut conserver l'universalité du
quotient familial
et puis par ailleurs ça a été ça a été
évoqué dans le reportage
il ya beaucoup à faire sur les places en
crèche dans notre pays où il ya
seulement 30 % des demandes qui sont
couvertes
alors que c'est un outil aussi une
nécessité il faut accélérer la
scolarisation des enfants à partir de
l'âge de deux ans je suis dans un
département où seulement 4 % des moins
de trois ans sont scolarisés en
maternelle ce qu'est le département la
seine saint denis qui a le plus faible
taux de scolarisation des enfants de
moins de 3 ans il ya beaucoup de choses
à faire aussi sur la revalorisation des
allocations familiales notamment pour
les familles des plus modestes mais on
ne peut pas il ya toujours un piège avec
ce gouvernement ils font un peu la même
chose sur les cotisations sociales
c'est d'ailleurs qu'on touche à des
principes universels la sécurité sociale
le quotient familial pour un pour les
familles et puis par ailleurs la
redistribution pour aider les plus
modestes de notre pays c'est deux choses
différentes dans l'histoire de notre
politique ceci je vous entends bien il
faut tout de même rouvrir le débat sur
la politique familiale
quand on sait qu'un enfant sur cinq est
touché par la pauvreté aujourd'hui en
france bah oui mais il faut d'abord
s'attaquer à la pauvreté parce que si
vous voulez un enfant qui subit la
pauvreté je vous parle d'un territoire
la seine-saint-denis où c'est beaucoup
plus qu'un enfant sur cinq c'est d'abord
des enfants qui naissent dans une
famille où les parents sont touchées par
la pauvreté par l'absence de travail par
la précarisation de l'emploi donc on ne
peut pas avoir d'un côté toute une série
de lois qui précarisent un peu plus le
salariat qui diminue les ressources des
familles modestes qui amputent le
pouvoir d'achat des plus pauvres qui va
faire la chasse aux chômeurs comme on
l'a vu aussi cette semaine et en même
temps constaté qu'il ya des enfants qui
sont dans la difficulté et donc on sait
que la politique familiale aujourd'hui
remplie vraiment ses objectifs bon
d'abord la démographie dans notre pays
je les dis est positive
et plus positif que dans d'autres pays
européens moi je pense que il faut
renforcer les aides
à travers les allocations familiales ce
qui est autre chose que c'est donc sur
les allocations familiales qu'il faut
que les allocations et l'accompagnement
de l'arrivée de l'enfant dans la famille
c'est à dire les congés maternité et
congés paternité qui doivent être plus
long les places en crèche augmenté il
faut je pense un grand plan de création
de places en crèche dans dans ce pays
c'est à la fois de l'emploi et et puis
des choses positives aussi pour
l'insertion de l'enfant parce qu'un
enfant
plus l'enfant est dans une situation
familière car ise ou pauvre plus il est
à la porte des infrastructures il
apporte des crèches il à la porte des
écoles avant trois ans donc c'est aussi
ça qui contribuent à la grâce d'un
cafouillage au sein de la majorité à ce
que tout de même vous région vous vous
réjouissez du fait que les luttes
sociales de cette majorité veulent se
faire entendre
oui mais je là pour le coup oui je me
réjouis bien évidemment qui est des
députés dans la majorité de plus en plus
qui expriment de la réserve sur un
gouvernement qui est quand même un
gouvernement très unilatérale en faveur
des plus riches de ce pays mais et qui
expriment des de la réserve ou un doute
bon ça c'est tout une bonne chose mais
je suppose heures pour le coup que cette
proposition était une proposition on
pourrait qualifier venant de l'aide
sociale je pense que lé plus tôt c'est
plutôt une proposition amont de mon
point de vue assez irréfléchie et avec
une majorité qui est on l'a souvent dit
un peu hors sol et un peu dépourvus de
culture politique et historique
on croit pouvoir s'affranchir de
vieilles lunes et alors que c'est des
fondements du pacte social dans notre
pays